you
hurricane Irma has prompted a state of
emergency in Florida emergencies have
also been declared in parts of Georgia
and South Carolina where the storm is
expected to hit early next week
the huge hurricane comes just two weeks
after Harvey brought so-called 500 year
rainfall to parts of Houston but Harvey
another five hundred year floods are
happening far more often Kris Van Cleave
is in Charleston South Carolina which is
bracing for Emma
just two years ago the city had flooding
that could have been called a one in a
thousand year akane harvey left behind
in houston was deadly and devastating
entire neighborhoods were submerged
after rainfall totals exceeded 500 year
levels but as it turns out these
flooding events are not quite so rare
this was the third storm in just three
years to bring so-called 500 year rain
to the city clearly we're seeing extreme
events who would have imagined 52 inches
in Houston it's just unimaginable the US
has experienced at least 24 of these 500
year rain events since 2010 including
hurricane Matthew in 2016 the 500 year
term is a risk assessment tool used for
flood insurance but scientists say the
phrase is misleading it actually does
not mean that the event happens only
once every 500 years but instead that
there is a 1 in 500 chance this amount
of flooding will occur in a single year
a 100 year event has a 1 in 100 chance
of occurring researchers say these large
storms are happening more often as the
climate continues to warm rare events
could even become the norm
Michael Waner studies the behavior of
extreme weather events
he says global temperatures have
increased a full degrees centigrade in
the past century and those warmer
conditions can create more powerful
storms warmer air can contain more
moisture than colder air and more water
in the air needs more rain that can fall
in flood zones where populations are
growing look in a place like Miami or
Houston and in the past decades we've
had incredible developments
we're planning and looking forward we
have to make room for where this water
is going to go that was Kris Van Cleave
reporting from Charleston South Carolina
yes and answering questions we've all
been asking yeah that's right including
your husband pointed this out earlier
yes that this is important clarification
yeah not that it happens once every
hundred years that it's a 1 7 1 in 100
chance